[ Speaking French ]
[ Cheering ]
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SAY HI TO ALL
OUR FANS BACK IN NEW JERSEY AT
THE STONE PONY AT OUR DRAFT
PARTY.
[ Speaking French ]
[ Applause ]
KATE MADDIGAN.
>> WITH THE SECOND LEGISLATION
IS, THE NEW JERSEY DEVILS ARE
PROUD TO SELECT, SIMON NEMEC.
>> David: WELL IT'S A SLOVAKIAN
SWEEP OF THE FIRST TWO PICKS.
WE WEREN'T SURE WHICH WAS GOING
TO GO AT ONE.
THIS IS A BIT OF A SURPRISE AT
NUMBER TWO.
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED AT ALL.
I JUST WROTE DOWN NEW JERSEY
NEEDS DEFENCE AND THIS IS WHY
I'M NOT SURPRISED.
SIMON NEMEC IS A LEGITIMATE
PLAYER.
ROBUST, GOOD LATERAL MOVEMENT.
HE'S PLAYED A TON OF TIME IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS HE'S PLAYED THE
SLOVAK BIG LEAGUE SO THE TRUTH
OF THE MATTER IS, HE IS A STRONG
BIG BODY.
>> YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HERE
THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS DRAFTS
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF SEPARATION
BETWEEN PLAYERS.
SO EVERY GENERAL MANAGER WILL
SAY WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE BEST
PLAYER AVAILABLE.
YOU CAN ADDRESS THE POSITIONAL
NEED.
JASON YOU TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THEIR CENTRE DEPTH.
THEN YOU'VE GOT HUGHES.
I MEAN THAT YOU HAVE POSITION
FILLED, SO WHY NOT ADDRESSING
SOME OF ONE OF YOUR BIGGEST
NEEDS AND THAT'S WHAT NEW JERSEY
HAS DONE HERE.
>> THIS IS AN ELITE PICK GUYS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A TOP TWO ON
THE HORIZON WHO IS GOING TO EAT
UP EVEN STRENGTH MINUTES.
RUN YOUR POWER PLAY.
HE'S 200 POUNDS ALREADY.
THIS KID MAY BE CLOSE TO NHL
READY RIGHT NOW.
>> HE'S NOT THAT FAR FROM
PLAYING IN THE NATIONAL HOCKEY
LEAGUE.
>> David: LET'S HEAD TO JEFF.
>> THE SEASON BEFORE THAT THEY
HAD THREE FIRST ROUNDERS.
# ALREADY IN THE NHL.
THE ONLY QUESTION IS IS HE A
CENTRE OR A WINGER.
THIS IS A TEAM VERY MUCH THAT
YOU GUYS JUST MENTIONED.
ETHAN EDWARDS THE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN, HE'S A GOOD DEPTH
DEFENCEMAN FOR HIM AS WELL.
BUT AS PIERRE JUST